الاقتصاد والاستثمار بعيدا عن الازمات
المنطقه هنا في الرياض يبلغ مستثمرون
الصينيون وعرب 30 اتفاقا لمشروعات
استثماريه تتجاوز قيمتها عشره مليارات
دولار في المؤتمر العاشر للرجال الاعمال
الصينيين والعرب الوطن العربي
كتله او تجمع اقتصادي لا يمكن
مليون نسمه حجم التبادل التجاري بالريال
الحدود التريليون و600 مليون
ومؤخرا وخصوصا بعد اطلاق رؤيه المملكه
2030 اصبح في مشاريع واعده جاذبه جدا
تتعدد مجالات والتعاون والاستثمار الصيني
في العالم العربي وتتناول قطاعات عده
ابرزها التكنولوجيا والطاقه المتجدده
والصناعه والمعادن اضافه الى سلاسل
التوريد ويسعل الجانب العربي للتعاون مع
المستثمرين الصينيين الى اطلاق امكانات
هذه القطاعات من خلال استقطاب رؤوس
الاموال والخبرات والتكنولوجيا الصين بلد
هو مصنع العالم الصين لديها في
التكنولوجيا لديها في الذكاء الاصطناعي
لديها في في المعدات الالكترونيه في كل
مجال موجود الصين ولكن نحن نستهدف
الصناعات التي لها مستقبل وتعتبر صناعات
ذو قيمه مضافه تتميز العلاقات والاقتصاديه
العربيه بعمقها التاريخي لا سيما عبر طرق
التجاره القديمه من خلال طريق الحرير
القديم كما تعد الصين حاليا اكبر شريك
تجاري للدول العربيه فيما يسعى رجال
الاعمال في الجانبين الى رفع معدلات
الشراكه الاقتصاديه
التنك نوت اعتقد ان التعاون الاقتصاديه
بين الصين والدول العربيه اصبح اكثر اهميه
من ذي قبل بعد ثلاث سنوات من الجائحه
والازمات التي شهدتها المنطقه نعمل ما
بوسعنا لحفظ الامن وضمان استمرار سلاسل
التوريد يؤكد رجال المال في المؤتمر انما
اعلن من صفقات استثماريه على هامشه يمثل
جزءا يسيرا من طموحات الجانبين خلال
السنوات المقبله
فرص الاستثماريه عده بين الجانبين العربي
والصيني كشف عنها مؤتمر الرجال الاعمال
الذي تتطلع به من خلاله الى تعزيز التعاون
الاقتصادي مع الدول العربيه من خلال
تحالفات اقتصاديه قد تفتح المجال امام
تعزيز الحضور السياسي الصيني في المنطقه
بدر ربيعان الجزيره الرياض